welcome all McGann mangabey and welcome
to the year of the watersnake happy new
year my name is Joelle tan and I'm the
director of community engagement here at
why BCA I'm extremely excited about our
partnership with the long now foundation
our muse of ideas and culture and with
complementary missions why BCA and long
now often partner to present rich
out-of-the-box diverse dynamic programs
that address issues affecting us today
[Applause]
sorry this is a slightly longer
introduction than than most evenings we
have a few of us so I'm Alexander Rose
the director here at lung now as many of
you know us as the organization that
puts on these speaking events but
actually what long now started as was a
maker organization we started with the
idea of building a 10,000 year all
mechanical monument sized clock design
by Danny Hillis who's who's here tonight
and I came onto the project in 1997 we
finished our first prototype in 1999
that one's at the Science Museum in
London was about eight feet tall and
since then we've been working on the
full-scale version and there's been very
little released about it because we
didn't want to release anything until we
had something really done but tonight
for the first time ever released to the
public you're gonna see some of the
first machinery that's been completed on
the clock this stuff was machined up in
Seattle for the most part and assembled
here in the San Francisco Bay Area in
our shop in San Rafael and you'll the
the video you'll see are the very first
testing of a 10,000 pound weight system
for the 10,000 year clock that's all
stainless steel and ceramic unlubricated
bearings thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
talk about small batch manufacturing we
got a product of one there's some
distribution issues in that getting it
to the customers will be hard when it's
in a mountain in West Texas so we'll
have to get the customers to it but that
could happen later in this decade good
evening I'm Stewart Brand from the long
now foundation Chris Anderson I was
thought it was kind of as an economist
he was a journalist it at the Economist
magazine and but he's a journalist so he
has this nose for news and then he got
to be editor at Wired and still doing
economic stories but as an editor he
didn't have to sniff out the news
anymore he got to decide what was news
and then he went the level deeper that
all journalists really want I don't want
to just report the news I want to make
the news that's what Chris Anderson is
doing now please welcome
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart this is a big deal for
me I am I am a huge long now fan and I
every everyday in the car I listen to
the salt lectures on the podcast and I
can tell you there is no faster way to
get smarts than long now lectures at 1.8
X it's also very intimidating because
the server idea density is just
extraordinary in these and this is
especially a big deal because because
Stewart and Kevin Kelley and Peter
Schwartz who I think of as kind of a
triumphant who we're all here tonight
are my intellectual heroes and mentors
and I feel that I couldn't be here if it
hadn't been for them and everything
they've stood for so thank you Stuart
for everything you built so tonight I'm
gonna talk about three things I'm gonna
talk about industrial revolutions and
why they're a big deal I'm going to talk
about inspired by the long now motif and
in mission I'm going to talk about the
long arc of history and how perhaps a
thousand years of history the direction
of a thousand years of history is about
to reverse and then I'm going to talk
about the maker movement and why
something that may seem trivial and
Hobby ish is potentially a bigger deal
than even possibly the Internet let me
start by just sort of talking about
industrial revolutions the subtitle my
my new book is the new Industrial
Revolution I spend some time so
relearning
about industrial revolutions I was
surprised by a couple things first of
all the first Industrial Revolution
which we think of as being you know
largely the dark satanic Mills and all
that actually began much earlier than I
then I had realized it began in the same
year as the American Revolution in 1776
with the first commercialization of the
spinning jenny which was essentially the
simplest possible parallel processing
machine for manufacturing the spinning
wheel dates back to medieval times and
you see it in fairy tales and the
spinning jenny is really just a parallel
processing wheels where where
spend multiple threads at the same time
and it was originally powered by the
foot and this led to the cottage
industry of the late eighteen late
eighteenth century and then after the
foots it was powered by horses and after
horses was powered by wheels water
wheels and after that it was steam and
then electricity but fundamentally this
was a game changer this this single
thing the spinning jenny changed the
nature of production it allowed people
to make more clothes and they could wear
so they become producers it allows loans
it allowed them to increasingly move off
the land as the source of their of their
their their sustenance and it's Massa
pated many women by camilla allowing
them to create small businesses in the
home and these cottage industries have
built family oriented businesses now
very quickly these became feeders into
much bigger factories which were driven
again by the quest for more motive force
the foot power could only take you to
maybe six ten of these wheels horses
could maybe take you to ten or twelve
but then you needed to go to a water
wheel which mentioned meant you needed
to move to the rivers and to the creeks
and then you needed even more power and
you'd move to steam and that and that
took you to this cities and that created
the created modernity and when you when
you when you think about those early
days that the Industrial Revolution you
know initially what we think of is is
the sort of the worst of it the belching
smokestacks the you know the crowded
living accommodations the dark factories
but what fundamentally it did is it
moved people off the land and
concentrated them around cities which is
a big theme of Stewart's work and when
you concentrate people to cities when
people move to the machines rather than
the other way around as we done with the
mechanization of farms what people move
to the machines you end up with a
density that you otherwise wouldn't have
and with that density comes the need for
the infrastructure of modernity the
sewage system you know running water
schools transportation better housing
etc and one of the really fascinating
things about about
this move is what did to the human
condition we think of the follow the
factory town is being less healthy than
the farms than the bucolic countryside
that these people left but the reality
is is that although initially they were
a little dark and over built and and and
not so nice what they quickly what you
quickly realized is that is that you
when you build the infrastructure of
modernity and things like schools and
health care systems and clean water
systems people suddenly got healthier
and you know those those country those
cottage walls were damp and the brick
walls were not and you didn't have
access to schooling in the small village
and you've started to as they built the
infrastructure around the factories and
this is what it did it doubled life
expectancy you know the concentration of
humanity around the Moton machines
around the means of production ended up
building something that was better for
us at least better for our species in
terms of of life expectancy and and this
is what it did to the population of
England and Wales and that time and this
is what it did to the world this is a
graph I got from handy McAfee and it
it's really kind of profound this is
sort of the long arc of human history
this goes back you know to to 2000 BC
and and basically when you measure it in
terms of things like population and you
know quality of life indices nothing
nothing happened until until the
Industrial Revolution so the Roman
Empire Muhammad Jesus Plato Greeks you
know the Egyptians it all kind of
unmeasurable when you look at these sort
of core core measures of kind of a
species success which is their ability
to live longer and reproduce more now
arguing whether that that's a good thing
or not is a leap from another lecture
but the point is that it was a
game-changer it actually kicked in
slightly before the Industrial
Revolution largely due to the
mechanization of Agriculture so you can
call that a proto industrial revolution
on the farm but is really once we kind
of started to amplify human potential to
replace muscle power with machine power
that we were able to move to the next
level of progress in development as
and you know this is you know seen by
those metrics there's really nothing
that changes the game like replacing
muscle power with machine power of
letting us kind of move up the
evolutionary ladder from our you know
from our kind of you know
undifferentiated you know limbs to our
highly differentiated brains so that's
so that's kind of that's the first
Industrial Revolution there was a it was
a it was a machine revolution and was
about allowing us to to go from beasts
of burden to beasts a brain
the second duster revolution by the way
there's lots of argument about how many
industrial revolutions they've been and
whether they you know the assembly line
counts as one and you know whether steam
is different than the end and water etc
but I'm gonna just kind of move quickly
past that and say kind of in the long
arc of history the next Industrial
Revolution should be the digital one but
I'm not going to show you show a
computer I don't think it's about
computers now the computer this is the
1940s or you know a 50 set cetera but I
don't think the computers was really
what the computer was really what made
the digital revolution a big deal
instead I think what made it a big deal
was the democratization of that and I'm
not again showing a personal computer
although I could but it was
fundamentally the the the giving of this
means the production to everybody it was
the spread of computing to non
professionals to regular people that
change the game because it Unleashed it
didn't just replace brain power with
machine power but it allowed brains to
work together it unleashed these sort of
spare cycles this sort of you know dark
energy a cognitive cognitive surplus to
use the phrase that was just sitting out
there waiting to be connected and so
what I've used to here is an analogy I'm
gonna come back to this as we move it
back into manufacturing what I've used
this analogy is something that you
probably have forgotten about as a big
deal this was the release of the first a
laser printer this is the apple
laserwriter from I believe 1986 I'm sure
someone here will be able to correct me
I think it cost about $6,500 when it was
released but but with it came came this
thing called desktop publishing
and I realize that desktop publishing is
not a mind-blower anymore but it was at
the time because it did it did an
amazing semantic trick which is that
took an industrial act called publishing
which used to be done in a factory
called a printing plant and it just
added the word desktop in front of it
we took a industrial act and we made it
personal desktop publishing and and you
know the means that the mechanism of how
this was done was kind of interesting at
the time it was the laser printer was a
high-resolution printer but more to the
point it spoke a language called
PostScript and as a matter of fact that
first laser printer which came out a
year after the Macintosh had more
processing power than the Mac itself
because you know parsing this is this
language of hub industrial printing was
so complex but what's interesting about
this a language PostScript is that it
was what we call scale-free that same
language drove the printer on your
desktop and also the biggest industrial
printing plants in the world that you
could prototype something on your
desktop and then upload it or I guess in
those days put it on a floppy drive and
carry it you know to a printing printer
where it could be made in any volume and
now you had the ability to slightly
harness professional tools personally
now again it was expensive and it was a
little hard to use but but the other
element was this software that desktop
publishing software was available for
everybody and you didn't need you know
500 years of sort of printing technology
dating back to Gutenberg and these terms
of Arts and these skills now are just a
point-and-click experience and yes we
made a dog's breakfast of pages you
mission together fonts and horrible
things but we quickly learned we learned
about letting and and kerning and
wraparound and flow and all those terms
of arts became something that was became
almost second nature but that only
allowed us to make a few no one was
going to compete with the New York Times
with the laser printer and then we
democratized
the other necessary step not they not
the tools of prototyping but the tools
of distribution and that was the web and
the web allowed you by transmitting
digitally to again break through the
barriers of scale
now everybody could reach the world's
population it was the barriers
and tree had fallen to zero it was again
a scale agnostic method and it had it
did not discriminate between the
professionals and the amateurs between
the credential and the uncredentialed it
didn't discriminate between businesses
and and and and regular people it didn't
discriminate between the good and the
bad it was an indiscriminate
distribution system and that liberated
creativity and that's where we find
ourselves today and you know I think you
know we forget how magical the moment we
live in everyone in this room has
clicked a button said that says
published and potentially reached eight
billion people and the fact that you
know something that used to be a factory
something that used to require
professionals in unionized typesetters
to do is now a button in your browser is
kind of magic and and ever you know I I
forget to to kind of like Marvel when I
push that button but yet we should it is
kind of an extraordinary thing that
we've taken you know what Marx would
have described as the means of
production and basically made it to
something that is available to everybody
and that we all have the same power now
you know whether your words are gonna be
read or picked up or go viral is another
matter but the fact is we all have the
same means of production so that was so
that's the power of democratization
that's why I think that it's not about
the technology but more about who's
using it and the power of the digital
revolution is that it let everybody use
it was agnostic as to as to as to the
credentials required to use it and you
didn't need any and so fundamentally it
opened up a huge pool of talents and and
energy and ideas and context and I don't
need to say anything more about it
created the web so that's what this
that's what the Second Industrial
Revolution did
now the third so the third is the is the
combination of the first two its
manufacturing and digital it's digital
manufacturing and once again I'm not you
know this is not super new factories
have been digital for decades and that's
not the breakthrough that's great and
it's been highly you know it's been good
for productivity and we you know we have
our iPhones to thank for that
but just as it took you know say say
3040 years for the mainframe to turn to
the person computer we've waited that
long for digital manufacturing to become
personal for digital manufacturing to
become democratized and so the full
potential of the digital element can it
can now be realized so you know we talk
a lot about you know so the fact that
the factors are automated is not a big
deal it's been true for a long time and
I I think you know let me quick quick
show of hands how many people here got
to visit the new me Factory down in
Fremont the old so Kevin I know you did
you had a fantastic tour of it so a
small number of you did this was the
this was the gold standard of 20th
century manufacturing technologies I'm
sorry that's the best picture I could
get but it was a collaboration between
Toyota and GM to basically take the
Japanese lean manufacturing methods
bring in the state of the arts of sort
of 1990s
you know automation and create a factory
of the future there's a really good by
the way I think this American life I
think it's an NPR This American Life
that we sort of talked about what went
wrong but suffice to say it closed down
and it turned out that that it just just
wasn't a flexible enough it made may be
well you know made one kind of car
actually has three kinds of cars quite
efficiently but in the end the the
marketplace demands I wanted more
flexibility and and I recommend the NPR
history to hear more about it but the
point is simply that that was that was
that was 10 as 12 years ago and then
Tesla bought that Factory or basically
got the rights to that factory for a
song and put in place another car
factory this is just ten years later but
this is what the Tesla factory looks
like and if you get a chance to visit
the Tesla factory right now and in in in
Fremont you should because you know not
for nothing did was Iron Man based on on
Elon Musk and you know his factories
this thing is unbelievable
but what's what you're seeing there
looks superficially the same
you're once again seing machines making
cars but the difference is that the the
nume machines were custom each machine
did one job and they were they were they
were extremely hard to program and very
inflexible and you know once you kind of
got the whole factory up running and
doing one thing you kind of didn't want
to change it you just churned it out
once one after another and every machine
was different the welding machines were
different from the painting machines
were different the stamping machines
which are different from the sewing
machines and the testing machines and
and and the wheel applying machines etc
what you're seeing here is that all the
machines are the same
these are cuca robotic arms from germany
stay of state-of-the-art robotic
machines but but the point is is that
they're general-purpose robots every car
can be different and today the American
cars they could be making washing
machines on the same line these these
robot arms have this these racks of
different tool heads and they can change
their function simply by going and
grabbing a different tool so they can be
a welding robot or a bolting robot or a
door closing robot or a wheel plying
robot and there's hardly a person to be
seen on the floor and that's and and
what looks like a subtle difference
special single-purpose
specialized robots versus
general-purpose robots is actually
transformative because fundamentally
what this allows is flexibility and
flexibility I'm gonna argue is is this
is the is the key the key winning factor
of the 21st century because flexibility
allows you to move faster it allows you
to operate in smaller batches and it
allows you to personalize every Tesla
can be different if you go to a BMW
factory or Mercedes factory any high-end
car factory they're all the same they're
all using these flexible manufacturing
systems so this is what digital
manufacturing looks like on the
industrial scale and that's why and
that's why this this era of automation
is different from the last ones the last
one but I'm gonna go further than that I
want to show you a video if I can just
tab over here and I want to show you a
video of a of a robot at work this is
not sped up
that is in real time and it's doing like
a little like that little sort of a
trick they do in the streets of New York
where they hide the beam under and it's
wants you to kind of watch that and and
think a little bit about the human role
in the world human place in the world
it's kind of mesmerizing so that's what
robots can do today they're really fast
and they're really accurate and they're
increasingly cheap the rethink robotics
that rodney brooks new company has a
baxter which i'm not actually showing
here a post should have the baxter robot
cost $22,000 what's brilliant about it
is that it's it's a torso with arms and
a head it's kind of human sized it comes
on this little sort of wheeled wheeled
platform and you kind of imagine this
the usage the use case what's great
about this robot the the Baxter is that
you don't program it to you reach behind
it and you teach it like you would with
a child and in the scenario I have in
mind and this is probably not what
Rodney has in mind is that is that you
you you go to your to go to your
whatever your factory is or your bakery
let's say and you're putting cupcakes in
a box you have an employee puts cupcakes
in a box and you sort of think a robot
could do that and so what you do is you
buy a Baxter for twenty two thousand
dollars which is like a you know less
than an annual salary and you and you
wheel it in and you and you tap you tap
the guy on the shoulder and he learns
turns up and you ask him to move his
chair over and then you wheel Baxter in
and then you tell him that he's got in
one more hour of employment and that his
job over the next hours to stand behind
and show the robot how to do his job and
then he'd collect your your your
severance if you're lucky on the way out
and it's a little scary but you know
this is this is kind of what's becoming
possible so so you know what does this
mean for the future of work and what I'd
like to argue is that is that this is in
this is going to
verse the era of globalization and what
I mean by that is that you know
globalization and by that I mean sort of
you know the quest for cheaper labor and
this goes all the way back this predates
the Industrial Revolution the quest for
labor cheaper labor has moved us largely
East a little bit south largely East for
certainly since since since the
sixteenth 1700s the original you know
spice theater there the the the the
spice lanes and that was a quest for
resources but then very quickly once we
began to manufacture things and move
them around the world efficiently we
went for cheaper labor and that took us
largely to to China to India other
places like that but when you see these
robots what you realize is that is that
is that labor is increasingly automated
China's adding robots as fast as we are
and we eyeball by robots for the same
price and so what that means is that
labor arbitrage no longer drives trade
the labor cost of products the shrink is
a tiny fraction shrinking every day and
as robots do the work you don't see
Geographic differentiation labor
arbitrage was a geographic quest for
cheaper people and now as you remove
people from the equation what's gonna
drive the arrow of globalization what's
going to decide where things are made
and I'm going to argue that that's time
I think we're gonna make things where we
can make them fastest Stewart mentioned
I just quit my job
I'm December I quit my job as the editor
of Wired where I'd been familiar twelve
years and and took over as CEO of my of
my robot company you can sort of see
where this is going
and we we make we make we make drones
which I hasten to add do not replace
very many humans they largely do jobs
that aren't being done well which is
putting cameras in the air we'll save
that for the question period but but I I
based in San Diego and we have a big
factory in Mexico and right but I live
in Berkeley and I decided to to open an
office in Berkeley and and this is where
I opened it I opened it a furniture
factory called swerve on 7th Street
and I open two just gonna have to know
this guy and he seemed kind of
interesting and I ended up being
co-located with the first your company
and when you visualize a furniture
company you're probably thinking of wood
and labor and all that kind of stuff
well you can't make that kind of
furniture in Berkeley what if you're
making and this furniture tends to be
quite metal and it also be high-tech you
know lots of Silicon Valley companies
get it but the way you make furniture in
Berkeley is with this this is a fennec
arm which Lowe's Mori Seiki CNC a 5x is
CNC in the back though the machine in
the back is CNC stands for computer
numeric control and it's basically a
milling machine so it's a machine that
makes your iPhone actually quite exactly
the same thing that Mori Seiki I mean
typically that machine the way it works
is that machine is the door and I'm a
block of metal a worker takes a block of
metal and puts it in the machine then
the door closes the machine and makes
the part and the worker picks up the
finished part and puts it in a bin but
that's too much labour and so now they
have a fanuc arm that loads the blank
and picks up the finished part and it
works all nights all day it's called
they they called lights-out
manufacturing because there's no need to
have the lights on the machines don't
care and they and the only reason that
the workers have to come in at all over
the weekend is because the bin where the
where the little metal filings come out
of this fills up and they haven't
figured out how to get a bigger bin and
so they all have to do is come in and
take a shovel and empty the bin of
filings takes them takes them 20 minutes
then the machine goes on and this is one
of the most advanced manufacturing pods
in the world and it's in a in its own
seventh Street in Berkeley and even more
importantly the designers of the
furniture are ten feet away and so what
you're looking at here is how you get
fast flexible short supply chains this
is the way you can link design and
manufacturing this is the way you can
manufacture in market this is the way
you can make every furniture different
this is the way you can get the product
to a customer two days after it was
ordered this is this is fast and this is
flexible and this is
near and this is this is starting to
look like a future of American
manufacturing that makes sense it
doesn't create jobs the way the old
manufacturing model did it's not going
to replace all the jobs we lost in the
70s and the 80s but it does bring the
parts it does bring the manufacturing
back to us but more to the point it
brings a different kind of manufacturing
back this manufacturing is is extremely
efficient in that it's in that as well
here I've got that might but forgive
forgive me give me the the bullet points
but this is what's different about this
kind of manufacturing it's you can
change its every day you can change the
design by the day you don't have to
order huge batches of the same thing
that mass production model that's driven
manufacturing for hundreds of years it's
all about one size fits all it's all
about finding out what the you know the
lowest common denominator the mass the
mass wants because that's the units that
that kind of get if you're gonna if
you're gonna you know you're gonna ramp
up a factory and fill the containers and
get put them in the trucks and get them
on the shelves of Walmart that's a like
a year-long process that involves units
of millions and that's great for spoons
and things like that but what about
everything else
we saw what the internet did to mass
media we saw what it did to one size
fits all my first book the longtail was
all about that we recognized that once
we liberated the ability for a small
batch and micro and niche but suddenly
we realized there was demand for things
that were not you know the blockbusters
and the primetime and the bestsellers
there was demands for things that
defined us as individuals that didn't
just define us as a group and now we can
apply that same model to physical stuff
because the means of production are now
as flexible and as unique as our own
taste let me give you an example so we
as my company we used to make a lot of
stuff in China and we learned that it's
there's basically four terrible things
that happen but we used to live in China
and I'm a huge sign of file and I have
massive respect for the Chinese
manufacturing model which I'll talk
about in a minute but as a customer of
it I realized that there were some
intrinsic limitations the first is that
it's really oriented around big batches
like like you know we were making
circuit boards you kind of got to do
basically it doesn't get it don't get
any kind of decent pricing or economics
for less than five thousand you really
want to go up to 50,000 etc what that
means is that all of your cash goes into
the supply chain
you basically have to write a check for
like you know 50,000 of them before the
factory spins up only then does it show
up you know months later it comes and
you get it and then you can get the
product into the marketplace and to get
the money back but all your cash goes
into the supply chain ahead of time the
second is that it is as I mentioned slow
and it was good to hear that we're on
Chinese in New Year Happy New Year
everybody the tech industry is shut down
for two weeks you know anybody who's in
the hardware business right now is that
Chinese New Year is the worst two weeks
of the year because because we're so
dependent on Shenzhen and the Guangdong
you know production you know world and
every we know it's the calendar week you
know when Chinese New Year is and every
year we get it wrong I mean our own our
own orders went in we thought four weeks
before Chinese New Year was sufficient
to get in before New Year turns out that
everyone else was going in six weeks
before and it's it's just you know every
every year we get two weeks to remind
ourselves the cost of globalization the
third the third problem is that if you
made a mistake if there's an error or
defect you've just made a big batch
mistake and you've got you've got not
like you know 50,000 of these things
they either have to throw away a rework
and so there's an entire industry of
factories that will rework the mistakes
of previous factories which is which is
which is tough but the worst and this is
the most most corrosive pernicious
consequence of that kind of outsourcing
is that it is death to innovation
because think about it let's say you
just designed some widget okay and
you've now put it into the outsourcing
thing and because of the economies of
scale you've got to do 20,000 of these
to get any kind of decent pricing and
wait months to show up and now they've
showed up you need to sell them and need
to get the money back and you can't
change the design until you've sold out
so basically your disincentivized
to innovate until you've sold your first
design and so what this whole
thing does is it basically sort of says
don't change a thing
don't change the thing because you got a
soul that sell the old thing it's a big
batch means slow innovation and that's
just not the way the world works today
and that's definitely not the way the
web works so you know what we're talking
about is shorter supply chains
I realize it's kind of wonky but short
supply chains are really cool they're
faster supply chains are more flexible
supply chains they're more sustainable
supply chains you're only making what
you need you're doing just in time they
you're not shipping things 9,000 miles
around the world so they have lower
carbon footprints their short supply
chains are a good thing we've seen what
short supply chains changed mean for
food that's why we have the locavore
movement and artisanal and and you know
the reason we go to the farmers markets
because we like short supply chains in
our food we like short supply chains
with our media that's where we have the
web you know it says it's one click
across you know to the server and short
supply chains are all equally good for
manufacturing just hard to do until
until recently until we managed team
make things digital and take the labor
component increase thing out of it so so
that takes me now to the maker movement
and I wanted to say the maker this is
Maker Faire in a quick show of hands how
many people here have been to a Maker
Faire yes great so you I I almost don't
have to tell you anymore it is a it is a
fantastic experience and not every time
I go and run the booth I'm just kind of
like who knew I mean the the garages of
Silicon Valley opened up and everybody's
doing cool stuff and the kids are doing
cool stuff and it's just inspiring and
it's great that it's physical stuff as
well because because you know turns out
that was all happening behind those
closed doors we just didn't know it
because we didn't work together we
didn't do it on the web so I'm gonna I'm
gonna tell story but well I'm telling
the story I'm gonna I'm gonna ramp up
this machine this is this is um I should
go back to here um so I'm at the first
Maker Faire I I saw my first 3d printer
and it was a call to cupcake from
MakerBot and by the way Neil Gershenfeld
of from the MIT fab labs is here tonight
and Neil you want to put up your hand
Neil is a neil is sort of the
intellectual godfather of the whole
concept of a being a personal
manufacturing desktop manufacturing than
3d printing and all this kind of stuff
so so you know I read his book you know
fab when it came out and was blown away
but I didn't have one until I went to
make it fair and I saw I saw a MakerBot
so this is a MakerBot which came out of
out of the maker out of the kind of the
open-source hardware movement it's it
was largely enabled by the fact that a
patent expired and then there's things
like Arduino the open source computing
platform this is Sam I have a first
MakerBot I haven't liked number 380
which was a cupcake and those days it
was a bag of parts and you put it
together and let's just say that I never
actually got it working but this is a
second-generation MakerBot call thing at
matok which still has some sort of you
can see let's see some of its heritage
it's still laser cuts and you know you
know it's kind of screwed together I
actually did not put this together
somebody much more competent than me did
and this one actually does work and you
know to be honest I'm gonna I'm gonna
take a big chance here and we're gonna
do I'm gonna try to make while we're
sitting here okay we're gonna trying to
make the classic 3d printing object
which is Darth Vader's head so right now
it's going through a calibration and
heating process my children have this is
my children's MakerBot and we'll talk a
little bit more about it
but this is kind of this is this is sort
of reminds me a lot of the whole Maker
Faire experience which is to say it is
not as shiny and polished and
professional as you know the commercial
products but is mine and I'm gonna do
something different with it and I'm
gonna think about the prodigy and find
some use for it so whoa so what this
machine liberated me was a memory and
that memory was of my grandfather
it's a Fred Houser Fred Houser was a
Swiss immigrant to Los Angeles in the
1920s and 30s he was a kind of a very
undistinguished swiss engineer he
actually never had a college degree and
he became something of an element of a
refugee you know he could not see
couldn't see a career for himself
there by the way this is heating up it's
got a heat up that's its tool head and
it's build platform and once it heats it
will it will do its thing I he came to
the United States because it for
opportunity and so he went to Los
to work in Hollywood which was a
mechanical business in those days he
worked for MGM working on the the the
talkies the first loops for tape for
audio tape and by day he cranked gears
in Hollywood and by night he he invented
stuff and this is him in his head his
work table and he was he was he was
super happy there this is it's kind of a
kind of a quiet guy and and but he loved
he loved to take his ideas and make them
real and he did his first on paper and
then and then he made a prototype and
what he invented my grandfather was the
automatic sprinkler system so if you
have an automatic sprinkler system yeah
my grandfather ii think it's the it's
the one you know it's a little wheel
that with a little pegs that go in for
the hours and it goes off when the hour
comes and and this was the first one and
and and this is something that's on our
wall in our house and this is this is
something he had a very kind of mixed
feelings about this is his patent 1949
if i'm not mistaken this is the patent
for the automatic sprinkler system and
and this was something that he felt was
basically the best thing about his life
and in some ways the worst the best
thing about it is that it it recognized
that he in fact had invented this and he
had the full authority of the US
government that gave him this this this
badge of recognition what he hated about
it is that is that it was a pain in the
ass he had it was lawyers it was expense
it was time he was a completely
unnecessary process that he was forced
to go through by the limitations of the
20th century manufacturing model which
is to say if this ever wanted to see the
light of day he was going to have to
patent it so that he could license it so
that a company with a factory could make
it and this is the way it came out it
was the Moody rain master it was it
allowed you to go to the beach while
your garden water itself by the way when
you think about this if you imagine you
know Los Angeles in the 1950s for
example it is it is their greening the
desert there's there's they finally got
the water they got the irrigation
everyone wants the green lawn and people
would come home and they'd already
invented those kind of cool sprinklers
to go just like that
you had to turn on and what would a
Swiss engineer do when he saw that a
Swiss engineer would put a clock on it
and that's exactly what an automatic
sprinkler system is so this this
liberated you now to to to get in more
Sun time and this this picture this
picture sir fills me with a little bit
of shame and I'll tell you why I would
spend my summers with Grandpa and one of
the last summers I spent with him in the
in the late 70s so this thing is now
going to put a do the raft underneath
this our Darth Vader head and so in the
summers I would spend I visit him and
one summer he took me to the factory
that made the the rain master and we
drove there and it was clear they had no
idea who he was eventually somebody
somebody was found who knew who mr.
Hauser was and they said Oh mr. Hauser
had the patent that we license to
produce the rain master and they they
gave him a tour and it's clear he'd
never seen it before
he had no idea what was going on you
know they explained it to him very
carefully and they're very polite but I
felt I felt embarrassed I felt ashamed
of my grandfather cuz he seemed lost in
the modern world he seemed to have lost
touch with his invention he seemed to
have to have basically lost lost some
essence of this it wasn't his product
anymore or somebody else's product they
had productized it they commercialized
they changed it they'd modified as it
wasn't as one would um they'd done all
the normal things of taking invention
and making it real except for he didn't
do any of them and what I realized there
is that he was an inventor but he wasn't
an entrepreneur and at that point I I
felt that that was not a path I wanted
to follow he'd he had he had lost
control of his invention and losing
control of invention
he had lost touch with the process of
invention because it's more than just
the idea it's more than the prototype
it's everything else and you weren't
allowed to do that then this is how I
would spend my summers with him this is
me at about five or six learning how to
invent mechanical drawing with Grandpa
and this is me at 12
check out the a jeans jacket and this
was a this was a great moment this was I
twelve and this summer grandpa had said
when you come to Los Angeles is summer
we're gonna make an engine we're gonna
make a gas engine and it's like cool he
says I've ordered a kit so we got there
and there's a box and I opened them up
and I know what kids look like there's
gonna be you know the tree with the
parts ins got numbers and the glue and
the instructions and it's like inside
the box we're four blocks of metal and a
blueprint and I was like where's the
engine and he's like it's in there
we're gonna get it out and just like a
sculptor it cuts away the bits of this
marble that aren't the figure a skilled
machinist like my father and his machine
shop could carve away the bits of metal
that weren't the piston or the cylinder
and out of that from a blueprint and a
block of metal could come a beautifully
machined engine the reason I remember
this particular moment is that I was
doing the piston he let me do the piston
and he showed me how to use a micrometer
to measure it and about two minutes
after this picture wilt it was taken he
will discover that I did not in fact you
know how to use the micrometer and that
we just cut away too much and we had to
get another block of metal and start
from scratch and the lesson there was
for me it's not enough to have an idea
if you want to become an inventor if you
want to make something you need to be a
machinist you need these incredible
skills I mean a metal lathe is a
beautiful thing in the hands of a
skilled craftsman in this the curlicue
is peeling a pile up around your feet
and these polish devices come out of
this machine it's a marvel to watch but
I didn't have those skills I would never
have those skills he was trained in that
I wasn't so so I forgot about that this
is a movie that was a reminder of why
you should you know why we all forgot
about that in the 20th century this is
called flash of genius it came out a few
years ago is about the invention of the
intermittent windshield wiper there's
the one that pauses it had a little
timer circuit and it's very similar this
is a guy this is the fictionalized
version but there's the guy and his kids
and there's the prototype and it he's
got the got the commercial windshield
wiper and then a little delay circuit
and he's invented something and then he
makes this like mistake so he's just
like my grandfather rap until then but
then he does something my grandfather
didn't
which is that he chooses although he
patents he chooses not to license
instead he decides he's gonna make it
himself and so he and what that meant
was building a factory and what that
meant in those days was six years of
agony he he mortgages his house he's
starting to rent some space he starts
bringing in the forklifts and the
production lines and hiring people on
the production machinery 1961 1962 1963
and my memory serves it was 1964 in the
movie when he is leaving the factory
still unfinished it's in Detroit it's
raining he walks out the door dejected
turns the corner and sees the new 1965
Mustangs being driven to be unveiled for
the first time and their wins should
have light windshield wipers pause and
he realizes his ideas been stolen and
the movie then tracks his descent into
madness and it's very entertaining and
in the end he sued for bazillion dollars
and was okay and he recovered from these
madness and all that but the lesson was
clear don't dare don't you dare being an
entrepreneur in manufacturing don't you
inventors don't dare to try to own the
tools and put in a means of production
because it's expensive and the big guys
will kill you and you'll go insane and
that was hard and that's because it was
really really hard to make stuff back
then and the point is and what I was
reminded and what I remembered and what
I kind of learned when I got my first my
first MakerBot is that suddenly it's not
that hard anymore when I have an idea I
don't need to know how to machine
plastic or whatever the right equivalent
would be I just push a button and out it
comes and okay maybe plastics not so
impressive but I can push another button
on the web and it can come out via a
service like shapeways and my idea can
be produced and prototyped in titanium
or stainless steel or silver or at any
resolution or color and now suddenly
that big barrier to entry in making
physical stuff which was the skills to
prototype has disappeared in the same
way that the barrier to publishing the
ability to typeset disappeared with
PostScript in the laser printer and that
was a big deal
that's a big deal now and so you will
not be impressed by my green Darth Vader
head if in fact it does come out but you
will be impressed by the one after that
that's going to be in multiple colors
and the one after that that's gonna be
in multiple materials and the one after
that that's going to have the electrical
wiring embedded and the one after that
which is possibly indistinguishable from
a manufactured good and the one after
that will be biological and we can talk
about that later
but this that was hard and this is not
this is what a factory looks like today
this is tech shop down in Menlo Park
there's one in San Francisco just a few
blocks from here there's one San Jose
they're spreading around the world this
is the gym for manufacturing in the same
way that you go to a gym in you and for
$100 a month or whatever you have access
to machinery you wouldn't otherwise
afford or want in your home you have
access to trainers and we have access to
other people who are doing the same
thing which is inspiring this is a gym
for Manny from making stuff this has the
3d printer and the CNC machines and the
laser cutters and the CNC embroidery and
the scene si quilters if you've never
seen a CNC quilter it's an amazing thing
there's one just down the street I'm on
seventh and mission seventh and Howard
and the software tools to use them and
also the traditional manufacturing of
the metal lays and all this kind of
stuff and the electronics tools and the
injection molding and it's just stunning
I mean I warn you if you go into there
you will be tempted to quit your job
matter of fact I did um so what's
interesting about this is I just want to
kind of point out a couple people
because I like them in this picture the
guy here in the front here is making a a
wireless control module for the smart
grid the electric grid and when he's
done when he's done with these there's a
little bitty small batch he puts this
label it says ABB on them and that's
because it's ABB to Swedish engineering
firm and they're actually the ones who
distribute it and sell it and when you
buy from ABB you assume it's made in
some massive Swedish factory if that's
possible
but in fact it's made by this Guy'd tech
shop and if he needs to make more he'll
just outsource it to you know to the
world's factories um the guy back there
is doing a vapor deposition chamber for
synthetic diamonds and way in the back
with the under the American flag that
doing a lunar lander because why not
so that's that's starting to look kind
of interesting the tools these hard
things are becoming easy this is a map
of maker spaces around the world or
hacker spaces they're sometimes known
and they're spreading all over the place
because again it's getting easy easy is
not to be underestimated easy is
liberating easy taps the pool of talents
and ideas out there that were turned off
by heart and what's what's cool about
this especially the new versions of this
is that they're easy and that's why
they're powerful so I showed you this
picture I showed you the analogy of
democratizing the tools of creation to
Ma critizing the tools of distribution
now this is the manufacturing equivalent
this is what desktop manufacturing looks
like yes this is the new MakerBot that
now he basically is like a microwave
oven you just opened the box and it just
works and that's great
we now are we now can make one of
something or two of something and
instead of some roughly a coarse
resolution called the somewhere between
the dot matrix printer and the laser
printer of manufacturing that's not
sufficient that doesn't change the world
that is not an industrial revolutions
not even a manufacturing technology they
call them rapid prototyping tools for a
reason the prototyping tools so how do
we get to an industrial revolution
remember PostScript what PostScript had
was fundamentally a language a digital
language that could drive the machine on
your desktop and the biggest factories
in the world and now we have it what's
driving this machine right here is
something called g code and g code is
the PostScript manufacturing that g code
will drive a 3d printer will drive a
laser cutter will drive a CNC machine
will drive all these digital
manufacturing tools what's great about
this is because it's digital it it is it
is um unencumbered by geography you can
upload it to the internet and you can
share it you wouldn't actually share g
code you share a higher-level language
for the point is these are digital files
and digital files start to act like the
web and once they act like the web they
tap the innovation model the social
model they tap everything has been so
magical over the last 20 years
once digital at once manufacturing
becomes digital it becomes social that's
the breakthrough so on the right here is
what you do with it so i mentioned that
the guy in tech shop was making a few of
of those wireless control modules but
that's again he's not competing with the
biggest the Honeywell's of the world how
would you do so and the answer is is
cloud manufacturing what I'm showing
here is a picture from a company called
Alibaba and I want to quickly sort of go
through this um Alibaba is a is a kind
of you know a web interface to largely
Chinese factories and what you can do is
you can upload a file to the factory and
they'll make stuff for you as I
mentioned I used to live in China and I
can tell you what it used to mean to get
to stuff made for you in China you had
to fly to Hong Kong you would have to
then get an introduction to factories
cross the border the mind or your
introducer and maybe translate it would
then inter take you to various factories
there'd be this really awkward
conversations where they weren't quite
sure who you were and what you wanted
but they give you a little tour you
drink some tea if things went well you
would then go and have dinner at that
point because you're the guest of honor
you would have to eat the fish eyeballs
then you know that went well you did you
do the ultimate hazing ritual was is
karaoke and if that went well they would
agree to do business with you which
required a letter of credit some bank
transfers and and that was the easy part
then he would have to figure out what it
is you're making and this exchange of
faxes and miscommunications and errors
and mangled products and months would go
by but after you were done with all of
that ultimately you could get the
world's factories working for you so my
experience was with Ali Baba was a
little different with my kids I made a
little sort of robot blimp and kits and
it was kind of cool and somebody and and
and we got maker maker make magazine who
has the Maker Faire and it has store
called the Maker Shed and they agreed to
buy some and so we I think we got him
ten which we made by hand and then they
said terrific now we'd like five hundred
turns out this is like this is like this
sort of like the whoops moment for all
makers is that when they are become
successful and you realize you cannot
sell a kit affordably if you're buying
the parts retail you have to buy them
wholesale duh so I said well I got I got
I got these motors I got these two
motors right now they cost seven dollars
each so I'm trying to get a whole
kid to be under $90 there's no way I can
make this kid I have to buy these motors
wholesale so I want Alibaba Alibaba to
look for wholesale motors and I found
this place that did it and I said I'd
like to buy some motors please and
they're like yeah what kind would you
like and like what do you got and
they're like what would you like and I'm
like what do you mean they're like
please design your motor I'm like I know
nothing about motors and like that's
okay here's this check boxes you know
what kind of shaft length and windings
and what voltage and what kind of magnet
types and I was like I check they've
just coached me through it check check
check check check
they said fine how many would you like
and I said 100 500 and they're like oh
okay
you could have 500 but here's the
pricing for 5,000 I was like that's
pretty good pricing I'll take 5,000 and
then they took PayPal and 14 days later
this box arrives arrives at my doorstep
and and and I open up this box and in
this box this I I had chills there were
5,000 motors and I'm just talking to
sander actually he had a recent
experience my experience um all the he
also just got some motors made in China
he's didn't end up quite as well but um
we'll talk about this in a second so so
the I never actually you know I never
actually seen industrial packing before
but there they were all there was these
little sort of foam divots and they were
all lined up and there was a slot like
they were there's this slight film of
oil over them because they just come off
the CNC machines these little sort of
plastic they're just layer upon layer
upon layer of thousands of motors and I
looked at this and I realized that I'd
gotten robots and China to work for me
and they took PayPal and I thought holy
crap I just harnessed the means of
production I'm not a company I didn't
have a letter of credit I didn't know
who I wasn't in Carroll I was I didn't
have to fly to Hong Kong I didn't have
to send faxes I just clicked on the web
for 20 minutes I didn't even know
anything about motors and they worked
for me and if I can do it anybody can do
it and in that moment I realized the
global supply chain had opened to the
individual there for a number of reasons
involving the
web generation coming-of-age in China
digital manufacturing making it
ultimately flexible the reason they
could make those motors for me is that
because it was all made by robots
everyone could be different and the fact
that they saw that there were better
margins on low batch on small batch
manufacturing and that serving
individuals by the web was a better
business than chasing thin margins in
mass production that suddenly the
world's factories had gone on the web
and now we had Clown Red Cloud
manufacturing and today their sites like
MFG comm and others that do this but
this is kind of cool we've completely
closed the loop we now know how to make
a few and we know how to make many you
can print local on your desktop and you
can print global buy through the world's
factories and just in the same way that
when you press publish in your browser
you're getting industrially sized server
farms and Google to work for you you can
now get industrial sized manufacturing
facilities to work for you with a click
of button and we are very close to the
day when manufacturer is a button in
your web browser so this is this is why
this is a big deal because we've seen
what happens when we democratize
technologies we've seen what happens
when we put power in the hands of
regular people that's called the web
that's called the personal computer it's
a big deal but manufacturing things
making stuff is a bigger deal and we now
have the opportunity to take all those
social models and innovation you know
mechanisms and architecture
participation and collaboration and
community that has worked so well in
digital space and now apply it to the
physical space and that's that's why I
quit my job so I told you my grandfather
invented the sprinkler system and as I
started exploring this I said what would
grandpa do today
if grandfather my grandfather was alive
today what would he do differently how
would you invent the sprinkler system
today now someone awkwardly we don't
really have much of a garden and I
actually didn't know anything about
sprinkler systems I had to go under the
house and sort of look at it just it's
kind of learn well well this is a valve
and that's a solenoid and anyway um but
grandpa did a sprinkler system so a
sprinkler system it must be and rather
than just think about it I decided to do
it so I said ok we're going to
- sprinkler system the maker way so I
kind of googled around and found there a
couple other people who are doing this
and this is it
this is it open sprinkler it's an
Arduino it's it's connected to the web
so that if it's gonna rain tomorrow it
knows that and it's not gonna sprinkle
today you can add all the sensors you
want to it and it's there's no
subscription free iffy and it only cost
$70 and you know you can turn it off
with your smartphone or your web browser
from your desk and and and you can
change it and make it better if you'd
like cuz it's all open source and now
this is not the best sprinkler system in
the world there are better ones out
there but this is mine and this was done
in about six weeks and the fact that I
could do what my grandfather never did
which was go from idea to marketplace in
six weeks and with a better sprinkler
system that sort of did in fact update
the automatic sprinkler system for the
21st century in my own little way was
kind of amazing and what was even more
interesting it turns out that main
market for this is hydroponic pot
growers who turned out to be they have a
very intense sprinkling needs also an
underserved community I'll have you know
so so so there was that now this was
only a thought experiment that I decided
to make real but in the course of doing
so I I had to make the enclosure and
this was another thing I knew nothing
about he never went made a dog's
breakfast of fawns and such with desktop
publishing well this is me making a
dog's breakfast of CAD and this is my
first cat experience in this enclosure
it turns out by the way by the walls
were way too thin but I downloaded a
free program was called Autodesk 123d
it's now called it's now released as
Autodesk one to 3d design but this is my
very first experience with with with cat
and it took about about three minutes
and I just want to kind of point out one
thing which again this is like the next
thing that I got chills okay so I told
you the desktop publishing was amazing
whether you remember that or not here's
something else that's amazing okay this
is not gonna impress you but it should
when you go to your word processor menu
and you go to the file menu and you pick
print and bits on the screen pixels turn
into atoms of ink through some
miraculous process of parsing and
vectors and rasterization and God knows
what when you press print and out comes
the piece of paper this kind of magic
you know bits turn into atoms right
there in front of you and this looks
beautiful and sometimes in color anyway
okay you're not impressed with CAD
programs you don't pick file print you
pick file make and at that point when
you pick make from these what happens is
that like you know five hundred years of
manufacturing skills and expertise and
technology gets turned to a software
wizard and it sort of says well would
you like to print that in 2d or 3d
would you like to print that here or
there on your desktop or using a cloud
surface what material would you like
here the Kostka implications of this
material versus that tel material oh you
would like to print in titanium a here's
a way to minimize the volume to cut down
the cost oh here's some of the various
sourcing types would you like to bring
the electron electronics into it kind of
this we've turned we turned like the you
know the global supply chain into an
algorithm that's on your desktop and you
know we're coming very close to the day
when manufacture is in fact a button in
your web browser so so check it out
these things are free you know if you
have your phone you can download on your
phone one two three designs on iOS and
your iPad and on your desktops on Macs
and PCs and and it's free and it's super
easy and manufacturing is now a button
click and that is kind of awesome so
what does that mean that means that in
the same way we all became publishers we
are all now designers and it's time to
get good at it what does it mean to be
good at designer well CAD used to be
hard right CAD used to be like $5,000 or
seat license you had to go to school to
use get by the cadiz computer-aided
design it's like the word processor 3d
images of 3d objects yes you had to go
to school and get training and
permission and only companies would have
CAD and architects and such like that
and now everybody has CAD you've got CAD
on your phone whether you're using it or
not if you use minecraft the game that's
CAD doesn't look like CAD but it is CAD
our children are growing up they're
fluent in in polygons because they play
video games they know how to translate
from 2d screens into 3d imagery they can
navigate virtual space they're good at
this
this is second nature to them it's just
CAD it's all the same thing it just was
called the scary thing called CAD rather
than designing stuff or drawing so I'll
tell you I want to finish with a story
of my of my children my wife Ann is here
and and and she she's will hopefully
forgive me for once again using my
children as props in my speech but my my
children are say growing up with that
with a MakerBot and and sort of what it
what what it does when you grow up with
digital technology manufacturing
technology in your home we remember by
the way what happened when this hat went
in our generation so remember remember
the home computer our parents got us
home computers they bought the family
home computer probably cost $2,000 it
wasn't sure what we had it it was you
know maybe the program kind of seemed
important to a child's education was a
shared you know device but those home
computers we figured out what they were
for now some of us thought they were
decide they were for video games but
others did in fact learn to program or
create or do email or something and
that's why we're here today it you know
that home computer changed the way our
experience with technology and liberated
something in us that brought us into
this room and now we have the
opportunity to grow up with digital
manufacturing to grow up with the 3d
printer in your home for about the same
price at about the same about the same
sort of level development so my children
go up with a 3d printer and my girls
will love the Sims The Sims 3 the Sims 3
is a videogame it's basically a virtual
dollhouse you build a house you popular
with people pull different furniture
they love it but at the end but they
have a limit on how much videogame time
they're allowed and at the end of AI I
think they're allowed at 2 hours a
weekend day and at the end this Hello
Kitty timer goes off and it's time to
stop and then they complain mightily
about about about about how they have to
play in the real world and we're like
you have a real dollhouse why don't you
play into real dollhouse and my girls in
particular complain they say well it's
not as good as the sin's dollhouse and
it needs this wait did you see I just
did this cool furniture this kind of you
know 1950's style furniture daddy can
you buy that for me please for my real
dollhouse and you know I know the answer
you know I know the answer is no but it
was parenting
to kind of get to know and so I said
well so it's the first first ice I
decided I would least have it informed
know so I've researched dollhouse
furniture you didn't think the speech
was gonna go in this direction of this
systematic failures of the dollhouse
furniture industry but so there's three
fundamental problems with dollhouse
furniture number one it's really
expensive like it like a like a kitchen
set with like three components it's like
$40 number two there's very little
choice you don't get you don't get 50
Styles dollhouse furniture you get like
Victorian or nothing and number three
and this one this one's really crippling
there was no system there's no
systematic standardization of size so da
furnitures come in all different sizes
the doll houses themselves come in
different sizes the people are not the
same scale as the houses and they're not
the same scale as the furniture either
because they don't bend properly they
don't sit in the chairs and if you get
one set it doesn't fit it doesn't fit
with the other one because there's no
standardization rant rant over so the
answer was no we're not gonna buy
dollhouse furniture but we don't have to
buy dollhouse furniture because we have
a 3d printer so we're gonna go online to
Thingiverse and we're gonna find cool
furniture designs so this was exactly
the chair they wanted by it's a lot of
fun they were delighted to see these
designs and once we found it we
downloaded it and we're ending the
software we did one thing which is
there's a little slider that decides how
big it's gonna be
and we scaled it just right for our doll
house and our doll house figures and
then we and then we printed it and then
they painted it and they loved it
and that simple act of dragging a
picking up the design from the internet
dragging the slider so it's just the
right size and then painting it turned a
consumption process into a creation
process and this is no longer a happy
meal that they're gonna discard it's no
longer some toy that was bought on a
shelf this is something they made it
wasn't hard they didn't have to use a
lot of skills but they put a little of
themselves into it a little creativity
they customized it for their own
interests and so it doesn't even sit in
the doll house it's just something on
there the windowsill because they
treasured this and
relationship with plastic is
fundamentally changed because it's their
plastic that they made and they changed
to reflect themselves this is that
design I just showed you that that how
did that design for that dollhouse
furniture get there and the answer is is
Casey Casey is by day she is a set
designer on Broadway
and in the old days it was set designs
they make models first like balsa and
cardboard but now she has a MakerBot and
she has CAD and you can see there's her
MakerBot in the background and here's
the set design and what she does is she
designs these beautiful sets for
whatever play she's done and she then 3d
prints them and when the producer signs
off they then fabricate them in at
full-size and off goes the set but then
what to do with those designs
she's the web generation we know what to
do with her ideas we we give him away we
put them online we share them and so she
puts them on Thingiverse and they turn
into my children's dollhouse furniture
she's not in the dollhouse furniture
business she's not she's not in the
furniture business at all she's a set
designer but what she did had utility
outside of set design and has a result
she has liberated a generation of
children too and her stuff is fantastic
check it out go to thingiverse.com and
check out pretty small things you will
not believe her her space station
playset is unbelievable
anyway that's what happens when you take
the web's innovation model and attach it
to manufacturing is suddenly these great
things like sharing and giving away in
communities and free Thank You Stewart
kick in and now if you're a toy company
this should fill you with terror because
my children don't need your stuff
anymore because they've got a MakerBot
and they've got the Internet
my boys meanwhile do Warhammer 40k mechs
so this is this is this is I told you
that today you know this is one tool
it's cheap and easy I told you about
cloud manufacturing is cheap and easy
this is the this is the other tool the
software this is Tinkercad it's free on
the web this is one of my sons a Toby
we saw Wally
the movie and he thought that it'd be
cool to make a Tobey robot and so this
is what he does for fun you know this is
this is kind of amazing so kids now do
CAD for fun and he doesn't know it but
he is that digital designer and he is
getting good at it and he now knows that
anything he can imagine he can make real
and he knows that it's easy and he knows
that it's free and he knows that there's
no one who's gonna judge his designs and
there's no one who's gonna say that's
not good enough
or you need to be a professional you
need to go to school to do that or you
need a credential in the same way that
no one judged us when we published via
blogs or when we tweet or when we use
the internet we could do what we wanted
and that liberated the creativity that
defined the last two decades so I want
to end just on this one note this is the
last bit of history that should blow
sure to blow in your mind at the time
maybe did blow to your mind the time but
probably doesn't blow your mind today
when Apple released the iPad iPod rather
the motto was rip mix burn remember that
rip mix burn what does that mean rip
means take a manufactured good a
commercial good and make it your own
digitize it bring it into your computer
mix change it burn remanufacture it
creating your own CD your own DVD ok I
get it it's just ripping and ripping
music and burning CDs and water CDs
anyway and but still it was kind of
unbelievable and it's time Autodesk has
a similar slogan which is kind of
unbelievable in his own way rip mod make
what does it mean to rip physical goods
it's called reality capture 3d scanning
3 scanning is a process by which you use
a technology to digitize to scan an
object to turn it into polygons again he
used to be very expensive technology it
is in your pocket right now if you have
an iPhone or an iPad right now download
a software maybe not right now but when
when you're out download a free software
app called 1 2 3 D catch from Autodesk
and and what it does is it uses the
camera just like you can see here use
the camera on your phone or your iPad
you just go around an object like that
and go click click click
click click click click it uploads up
the cloud it stitches it together and
creates a polygon like this so that you
can print a PEZ dispenser of your head
but what that means is you can photocopy
stuff so this thing right here in my
hand I would lie don't like it I wish it
were white or I wish it were titanium or
I wish it had you know blue horns
I just photocopy it for my logo more to
the point I just go click click click
click click
I've now ripped it I then import it into
these CAD programs Tinkercad whatever
which I can use because they're easy and
I change it maybe I'm gonna add my logo
and then I uploaded shapeways and have
it printed in titanium because that
would be cooler and I just photocopied
reality that's kind of amazing and by
the way to mention it's all free well
except for the printing and titanium
stuff which is actually super expensive
but but but the rest of it you know the
ripping and the mixing part or the rips
ripping in the modding part that's all
free in your your pocket on your phone
this is this is kind of magic you know
and this is this one again try it and I
suggest by the way you know daylight
works a little bit better and you know
make sure the contrast is good but it's
kind of the fact it works at all is
astounding there are massive questions
to get raised once you can photocopy
reality and make it your own
intellectual property is just the
beginnings of it I mentioned I showed
you the Warhammer figures that we did it
turns out that wait here's my other
complaint okay after I complain about
the lack of standardization of dollhouse
furniture here's gonna be a lack of
standardization in in base figure ratios
in warhammers Warhammer kids come with
11 figures and 10 bases I have no idea
why and so my boys say can you dad can
you buy us a box of bases and I'm like a
base is a circle it is a disc and like
no we have a mate we have a 3d printer
we are not gonna buy a box of discs
we're gonna make him and so I did this
is at this point I'm super good bit CAD
could I can actually draw a circle and
extrude it and I'd done and move printed
it look great and then I because you
know my own little sort of KC way I
I uploaded a Thingiverse and and to
share it and then it came time to to
label it they said okay it says title
and I'm like Warhammer 40k base
description this is a
for America 40k figures and I like
posted it and like within five minutes
the first comment comes in dude
you were in so much trouble the last
time somebody did this games workshop
who only this British company who owns
the warhammer line filed a DMCA takedown
they're coming after you ban take it
down so at the time I was the editor of
Wired and I thought this could make it
for a cool story I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna wait and see what happens
well nothing happened they wouldn't they
didn't come after me and so I was like I
was getting kinda bored so I went after
them and I said hey Games Workshop's see
what I did I posted this what are you
gonna do I was a little nicer about it
than that but and they said well well I
said you know it's just a circle are you
really claiming intellectual property or
you know rights over a circle and they
said what you call it I said I called it
a Warhammer oh yeah that's a trademarked
name the moment you called it a
Warhammer 40k base you're infringing our
intellectual property because that's our
name and like oh maybe you're
acknowledging you've ripped us off the
moment you titled it the Warhammer 40k
figure and I said oh okay that looked at
what other people did and what they all
did everybody else did and there's tons
of Warhammer 40k scan stuff out there
and they all did it's like it's like
base for board gaming figures and then
the text it says this is a gate based
football game or gaming figures do not
use it for Warhammer 40k if you want to
use a Warhammer 40k base buy it from
Games Workshop they're the best and you
know why they type that right so that
when you type Warhammer 40k into the
search terms up it comes right so let's
just say that this that we have not
completely figured out what intellectual
property is gonna mean by the way you
cannot you cannot copyright physical
stuff you can copyright words and text
and video and music be a can't copyright
physical stuff we actually don't have
laws to decide this we don't know how
many polygons is intellectual property
infringement here was a low poly
photocopy of reality okay but a high
poly not if what if I give it away I
know what
happens if I if I photocopy Bugs Bunny
or photocopy Mickey Mouse and sell it
but what happens if I photocopy Mickey
Mouse and give it away I don't know I
mean you know I'm not sure I should I do
know I get sued to death by Disney but
uh but I don't know one what grounds are
gonna do so and no one else does either
the fact that copyright does not apply
to physical things is a massive
challenge now that we all have the
ability to rip mod and make I'm actually
gonna skip I think I think I'm running
past this so I'm gonna skip past the
last part which was my own little story
and and just end up with this this is
this is a kind of like my slogan this is
my bumper sticker of what's going on and
it is Adams are the new bits and what I
mean by that is that is that the magic
of what we did on the web and the magic
of what we did with personal computers
and the magic of digital now applies to
the physical if you thought the web was
big I think this is going to be bigger
thank you very much
I mean I think that's it I'm gonna get
my water oh good idea
Cheryl you're supposed to sit there
I will you hardly mentioned open sores
how does that play in all this you know
open source is is my particular passion
but I don't think it's actually required
so well I mentioned that I mentioned a
couple things that were actually
open-source Arduino which is the
computing platform that we use for open
sprinkler and for all of our drones
which we may talk about later is an open
source hardware project MakerBot over
there is an open source hardware project
liberated by something called the RepRap
project house my house my Darth Vader
head going taking its sweet time taking
its sweet time now yeah this is why this
is why this is not a mass production
technology right we'll get there that
jaw is fully in place so so so open
source open source is you know when all
of you know very well I mean you had the
first open source conference I guess
didn't you you know but you were there
okay so open source is a very explicit
form of sharing which is to say it comes
with the license that requires you know
that everything it's derivative designs
be also shared and that's a it's a very
kind of hardcore form of sharing which I
believe in and everything we do is open
source but it's not required that you
know there's other forms of sharing
Creative Commons is a form of sharing
that's not explicitly open source and
sometimes just sort of giving away stuff
with no license whatsoever is okay so I
think that open source is is open source
hardware is it's an interesting
experiment on the kind of the hard core
side of what I'm doing but it's not the
maker movement is not an open source or
not synonymous so a question from Bob
copic what can't you make what shouldn't
you make ball bearings nano stuff can
you make nano stuff yet mm-hm well so
when I say me let's just say the tools
available today yeah yeah so so I'm
actually me Neil Neil's here and and and
you know about Neil's Neil Neil just
head it off so I'm gonna have to answer
for him because he's the expert on this
so here's what we can make
now we can make relatively you know
high-resolution metals plastics glasses
woods and things things like that we can
start to make them in multiple colors so
you know so it starts to look like you
know properly painted thing and we are
just beginning to make them out of
flexible materials and be able to have
wires inside what we can't yet make is
like the semiconductor is the chip
inside it we can't make you know multi
material things to have like the metals
and the plastics together and the same
you know pre-made in the same thing and
you know and we can't make them we can't
we can't make them in multiple in many
in many copies so this prototyping
technology is slow as you can see once
you move into mass production you have
to have to switch to a whole different
sets and that gonna go from plastic 3d
printing to injection molding and maybe
from the scene seeing to casting and
maybe from the you know the printed
wires to circuit boards and you actually
have to switch technologies when you go
from micro to mass but you know as
that's furniture factory I showed you um
once the machines get better then
actually digital's does start to scale
so here's that's kind of where we are
right now here's where we're going to be
so I think we're kind of in the dot
matrix period we're about to get to the
laser and then the color printer etc we
are going to get multi material we're
going to get the the electronics we're
going to get resolutions
indistinguishable from the from the the
mainstream from mass production after
that comes biology craig Venter the
biologist who you know very well is
working on a desktop DNA printer and the
scenario is is is this or RNA printer if
you will in the scenario is this I know
Ryan's in the audience and Scholes
she'll be horrified and probably notice
also much about this but so right now we
have flu season and probably many of us
got our flu shots did you know that flu
shot was a guess it was a guess based on
some calculation of what the you know
swine human you know exchange was in
China months earlier and the guess is
brighter or wrong or in any particular
time
what if rather than that rather than
their flu shot months in advance that's
a guess cost me wrong what if you got an
email from your doctor an encrypted
email let's say that says this is the
strain of flu that's actually arriving
right now this is the this is the this
is the this is the virus that's hitting
your town next week and send this to
your RNA printer and print out a little
vaccine a little sort of a little goo
which are put in your orange juice or
whatever and drink and you would have a
custom just-in-time vaccine that was
absolutely right now that would be good
for the flu it sort of raises the
question what could possibly go wrong so
right now if you want to so this is
basically this is a this is basically
it's called DNA DNA synthesis and DNA
synthesis is now about the this
machinery is about the length from here
to the podium but it's getting smaller
every year and pretty soon this can be
the size of that right now we stop
people from synthesizing smallpox by the
fact that it's only about a few small
number of firms that do Indians DNA
synthesis and they look for that what if
everybody has one how are we gonna you
know how are we gonna stop that that you
could have that genius out of the box is
you know you can't change you can't stop
me from making something cuz it
open-source technology well they're like
is the FBI is a lot hipper than they
used to be back in the days they lock up
a reactor that they could identify now
they go to the you know basically I gem
and bio hacker meetings introduce
themselves aside from that I'm from the
FBI I'd be weapons of mass destruction
if you see anything weird do you let me
know here's my phone numbers sure that's
that's probably the way it hasn't
stopped the hackers of course not
yeah well it's so services coming in
here's an element that I'm hearing about
the DIY bio Jason both I'm doing this
thing in Boston and Ryan and I were
asking so you know what's the sort of
level of innovation you guys are really
dealing with and he said what we do is
trailing edge innovation and what you're
describing here has very much that
quality absolutely trailing edge
innovation now what is and this sounds
like buckminster fuller talking about
you know the rudder is the main event
actually and it's after the ship has
gone by there's a rudder and then
there's a tree
and the last thing that happened is
actually what's controlling where the
ship goes are you're saying with a
trailing edge technology the trailing
edge innovation is going to turn the
ship I am a huge fan of trailing edge
innovation so the personal computer was
not the most powerful computer right
it's right the least powerful computer
but it was the only one you could buy
uh-huh you know it didn't it wasn't
sitting behind the glass while the gaas
in a room you didn't need to be an IT
guy need to be a corporation you could
own it so the great thing about trailing
edge technologies is that they are
accessible technologies and the most as
I say the most powerful thing about
technology is not with the technologies
who uses them are you know are we make
we put more drones in the air every
every quarter than the US military art
drones are not as good as the u.s. no
all disciplines and bring some drones to
you didn't ask
next time plus the small fact I didn't
want to kill anybody it's not with
mapping clapping not with weapons we
sort out of control robotics but but you
know art drones are not as good as that
gives military ones but but but you're
not gonna get a US military one and and
you're gonna think of non-military
functions and you're gonna think of it
in the same way that the internet used
to be military and then we found better
use for it once it became ours you
remember we started you know the
military Internet was was odd broadband
ours was dial-up modems but we did
magical things with them and the
personal computer was not powerful but
we did magical things with and this is a
terrible 3d printer hmm but my children
or other people their generation will do
magical things with it because trailing
edge technology is democratized
technology okay here's a question since
it's coming from a leaf else in the
spine I'm particularly interested in it
has the first killer app for 3d printing
yet appeared so what is it if not what
do you think it'll that is a great
question I get asked all the time I wish
I had an answer so I so I think that's
the way to answer this is it's like
saying first of all it is not unusual
for people at this stage of Technology
not to have an answer for that I'm sure
that Jobs and Wozniak didn't know what
the personal computer was ultimately
gonna be for and until the spreadsheet
or video game or whatever came out I and
there may not be one killer app in my
house dollhouse furniture is a killer of
3d printing but let me let me give you
an example so when the way
the color printer desktop color printer
came out did yeah what was it for the
answer was to print your fonts and color
right and that was not terribly
compelling and then we invented the
digital camera and now we know what is
for is to print our photos and at the
time people remember the time when this
first printers came out people thought
you were good to print the New York
Times it's that it's gonna be it was
gonna be distributed manufacturing of
mass media and they certainly thought
that you wouldn't be creating we
wouldn't all be creators we wouldn't all
be be writers we'd be printing out other
people's writings and that turned out
not to be true and very hard all all all
all writers not necessarily printing it
out but and that and those and those and
what we end up using a printers for is
stuff that we create
not because we're painters but because
we have cameras and we take our own
pictures and print our own pictures
rather than downloading for any other
people's money here still print
photographs okay maybe 20 questions on
Rob Knapp precious memories what will be
the immunological response of
established large-scale manufacturing
into the presence of this alien for
making things house is playing in China
for example first they ignore you then
they laugh at you then they fight you
and then you've won so I mean we're kind
of in the ignore face I think I think
they'd be maker movement particular is
and these things are dismissed as toys
and and and in substantial it's my you
watch this is my pebble smartwatch
anybody here a pebble smartwatch
okay pretty cool does it ever even heard
of the pebble smartwatch great okay so
this this is a Kickstarter project
Kickstarter is like the you know the
financing model of the maker movement
and what I love about this SmartWatch
this pebble smartwatch it was announced
on the same week as the Sony SmartWatch
does anybody here have a Sony SmartWatch
does anyone heard of the Sony SmartWatch
okay so one person has heard of the Sony
SmartWatch I love that this was designed
by four kids in Palo Alto and it blew
Sony away and I just think that's that
you know that you take a few more
examples like that a few more pebbles
blowing a you know for kids and sell a
palo alto blowing or kickstarter
projects blowing away
mass manufacturing companies and then
they're gonna start to pay attention
this is some new level of innovators
dilemma that Sony can actually figure
out and get in front of Sony in
particular and Apple say there's a
series of experiments with companies
releasing designed files to allow
innovation so for example I don't think
was Apple I think Nokia released a
design file the case for Nokia phone and
they're like you know so we'd like to be
cooler
you know we'd like to be cooler we think
the cases are kind of a way for people
to express creativity around our
products maybe make them a little bit
cooler you should not have to go through
the hassle using micrometer and
measuring the case and doing the cad
yourself here's the cat it's out there
we've given you all the mechanical
dimensions of what's necessary for a
case now you go at it but you know come
up with some cool designs or etch it out
and set there and make it and build a
business around it and we're gonna make
it easy for you so that's a little tiny
thing of releasing the design files you
know Nokia's Nokia it's not a trade
secret for Nokia just made it easy for a
community of creatives to build
businesses around them and no cat sort
of Lego does the same thing there's a
whole ecosystem of Lego of people doing
kind of long-tailed Lego making things
that Lego wouldn't make there's a
company called brick arms that makes
like like we get back to weaponry but
they make they make guns basically for
Legler because Lego doesn't like making
guns or a family or a new company but
kids like guns and the nice thing about
guns is that it keeps those a tragedy
for Lego is that their customers age out
at 12 and they lose them but they only
keep them to 16 they buy these 300
dollars you know Death Star you need to
bridge the gap from 12 to 16 and the way
to do that is with guns you know and and
halo and halo you know illegal halo
figures which Lego will not make but
there's a whole ecosystem of these small
kind of maker II companies that that
that they serve that market keep those
boys in the Lego world just that Lego
can get them back and they buy the okay
last question
these are seminars about long term
thinking and boy does this sound like
economist
now talk now you didn't mention this all
stuff that's happening you've got you're
telling us everything is getting faster
an end of this week and things are
trying to catch up you know the season
what's the long now aspect of this story
I would say the long now aspect is
twofold first of all it's the reversal
globalization is the fact that
manufacturing is no longer driven by
labor costs and instead by flexibility
so that's a 500 years yeah so let's say
so that's what done permanently thing
now manufacturing goes closer to market
cliff AG you know it's driven by
innovation driven by speed not money
okay that's kind of a that's kind of an
Einsteinian pivot right from you know
from the dimensions of money to the
dimensions of time but that so that
means that it could be the future of
American manufacturing means that you
know we now start to make things where
the ideas are rather than where the
cheap labor is and like yeah I don't
know whether how many jobs is gonna
create but that's that that's a that's a
kind of a millennial long shift
that's gonna play out the other one I
would argue is it's the long tail it's
the long tails stuff I mean it's it's
the if the ability mass no longer wins
the day at the end of the day you know
the you know the markets of ten
thousands Kevin Kelly hears is is you
know brilliantly written about about the
power of small markings by small it's
like some 10,000 take them to 10,000
this is a tough number right 10,000 is
too big for an individual and too small
for mass production mass production
doesn't get bad for 10,000 individuals
can't get up there so but what about all
those marks of 10,000 on the web we know
those markers of 10,000 they're called
they're called the web right it's nice
it's it's it's it's it's you know
discriminating it's it's you know
focused you know as a site so we could
do that because that doesn't because the
web doesn't care about scale now
manufacturing doesn't care about scale
and those markets of 10,000 which is
really the Kickstarter you know the
Kickstarter model or the HD model you
know those marks of 10,000 can now exist
and what we're gonna discover is there's
a new class of product out there that
couldn't exist before because they
violated this that you know that the
scale rules that will now exist and
maybe they're just gonna be better
versions of the old products maybe they
can be something we never thought of so
is this a Moore's law artifact and will
it slow down when Moore's law slows down
well yes I mean isn't Moore's law
it is absolutely driven by the march of
technology you know the fact that this
is cheap and easy is basically Moore's
law it it's you know and that's that's
great when you say when Moore's law
slows down you're talking about the
semiconductor part of Moore's law all
right there's also a biotech version
visit is four to six times faster yeah I
mean you know in my world in drones you
know what we're driven we call we're
driven by the technology inside your
smartphone which is actually more about
like MEMS sensors and about the camera
and about the GPS and about the software
and the wireless and if there's much
more than just simply the processor
itself and so when you think more
broadly about you know about about about
you know technology interacting with the
physical world
mm-hm which is about the sensors the
Internet of Things does that I think you
know we've just begun to touch what
Moore's law can do welcome the future
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you